الجديد للمعلومات حتى اللحظه
نعم قبل قليل اعلنت وزاره الطوارئ عن
العثور على مسيره ايضا هنا في ضواحي
العاصمه الروسيه
موسكوها المنطقه تم العثور على مسيره ايضا
كانت مفرخه ليست كبيره الحجم طبعا هذه
المسيره الان يجري
تفكيك العبوه الناسفه التي
موجوده معها يذكر ازدهار انه خلال الايام
الماضيه عثر على اكثر من مسيره مفخخه هنا
في ضواحي العاصمه الروسيه موسكو عندما
نتحدث عن ضواحي موسكو نتحدث عن مسافه
مسافه لا تتجاوز 70 او 80 كم من وسط
العاصمه الروسيه وبالتالي من الواضح ربما
كان هناك محاوله
استخدام اكثر من مسيره جزء منها من خارج
العاصمه ومن ضواحي على العاصمه الروسيه
وهذا المكان الذي اتحدث عنه يقع في شرق
روسيا وليس في غربها وبالتالي ليس باتجاه
الاوكراني اذا كنا نريد ان نتحدث عن هجوم
بالمسيرات من الجانب الاوكراني من الناحيه
الغربيه وبالتالي من الواضح ان هناك
عمليه كبيره كانت تستهدف منشات حيويه
نفطيه وعسكريه وايضا قصر الكرملين ربما في
الساعات القادمه ايضا نحصل على معلومات
اضافيه فيما يتعلق باشياء اخرى ربما قد
يفصح عنها جهاز امن الدوله والاجهزه
الامنيه الروسيه ازهار